as years have gone by with no additional
input from George Armand himself fans
have gotten very creative in theorizing
about Jon Snow or Daenerys being the
prophesied Savior some are even claiming
that supporting characters like the
Hound Davos or even ginjury are azor
Ahai but if this theory that I'm going
to introduce you with in this video is
true then the prince has already come
and gone and nobody even noticed
according to this theory just may not be
as real hi although he might still have
a connection to the prophesied Saviour
Westeros there's a popular theory
claiming that Asura High was actually
Rhaegar Targaryen Khan fans have often
heard of and finally saw in season seven
I'm sure you're wondering doesn't
principals promise have to be alive how
will he defeat the night king if is dead
well according to this theory he'll
defeat the night King the same way the
original azor Ahai did with his fabled
weapon Lightbringer except in this case
light bringer is not a sword but rather
person named Jon Snow in his youth
Rhaegar Targaryen himself actually
believed that he was the prophesied
Prince and so did his great-great uncle
maester aemon
before they both become convinced that
the saber of sexual records and a gun
instead Rhaegar I thought the smoke was
from the fire that devoured summerhall
on the day of his birth the soul from
the tears shed for those who died he
shared my belief and he was young but
later he became persuaded that it was
his own son who fulfilled the prophecy
for comment had been seen above King's
Landing on the night Aegon was conceived
and Rhaegar was earned the bleeding star
had to be a comet what full sivir
we thought ourselves so wise said
maester aemon in the face for Crouse in
case you don't know Rhaegar was born in
the Targaryen summer place summer hall
shortly after rakers birth the palace
was consumed by a great fire which
claimed the lives of King Aegon v
maester aemon's brother
the king's son and heir and the Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard the tragedy
is one of the more intriguing
backstories in Song of Ice and Fire
given its unexplained nature perhaps
Martin has been withholding details
until a timely twist that reveals how
the tragedy of summerhall helps fulfill
the prophecy of azor Ahai namely that
Dana's older brother was literally born
amidst salt and smoke as we all know as
her high said to be born amid smoke and
salt and his maester aemon said Rhaegar
Targaryen does fulfill the prophecy he
was born in summer Hall on the very same
day the castle burned to the ground so
there's a smoke but what about the salt
that day the kingdom also had lost the
current king at the time a prince and
the captain of the Kingsguard as maester
aemon pointed out those death did lead
to many tears sin tears are salty
however the fact that Rhaegar became
convinced his son was a prophesied
prince may not be far a feeder the man
had her brother's hair but he was taller
and his eyes were dark indigo rather
than lilac a gun he said to a woman
nursing a newborn babe in a great wooden
bed what better name for a king will
make a song for him the woman asked he
has a song the man replied is the prince
that was promised and this is Song of
Ice and Fire
then his vision of past in a Clash of
Kings of course fans know that the baby
Rhaegar was talking about Aegon's life
and enduring the sack of King's Landing
and the mountain smash his head against
the wall killed his sister a niece and
raped their mother Elia Martell before
killing her as well as Game of Thrones
star as the prophecies can be tricky
and while Rhaegar had the basics right
he was off in two key ways he considered
the wrong son to be the prophesied
prince and the right son is not actually
the prince but rather the weapon
ironically turns out that he was right
the first time he himself was azor Ahai
all along according to a legend azor
Ahai had to try a three times before
successful forging his flaming sword
Lightbringer the third attempt he
realized he would have to sacrifice the
thing he loved the most in his world the
successful creation of the weapon
resulted with the death of his beloved
wife Nissa Nissa who was said to cry out
in both anguish and excess even ezra
high-tempered the blade by driving into
her heart
similarly johnston was rehearsed her
child and his creation resulted with the
death of Reger's beloved wife Lena stark
who could be heard by her brother a dirt
crying out in anguish in ecstasy from
inside the Tower of joy as she was
giving birth to her son
so the samurais Rhaegar was born amid
smoke and salt he forged his ultimate
weapon on his third attempt and he
sacrificed his wife and John has since
become a little sword of fire most
assumed that part about Lightbringer
means that the original azor Ahai killed
his lover with an actual sword and the
sacrifice then imbued the sword with
enough magical power that it could drive
back the darkness here as her high kills
his lover with his other sword by
building the power of that sword Rhaegar
altom utley created a new weapon forged
with a loving wife's heart the end
product is a super weapon capable of
destroying the night King for good
instead of a magical flaming sword this
weapon is John himself there are clues
hidden throughout the show about his
true nature of life bringers forging
george RR martin uses the image of a man
stabbing a woman with his sword as a
metaphor for an intimate relationship
Elser in the books perhaps the most
prominent
we'll be a conversation between Fiona
and Barbie Dustin in dance with dragons
Brandon let his sword he loved to hone
it if one is sharp enough to shave the
hair from woman's car he was the same
and how he loved to use it but his sword
is a beautiful thing hit only once long
story short it turns out that while fans
have been eagerly waiting the revelation
of Westeros Savior the men's time has
come and God regarded not stab Liana to
the heart because he interpreted the
other high prophecy correctly the
forging of Lightbringer is referring to
the conceiving and birthing of a child
rehgar fulfilled his destiny when he
created sword in darkness light bringer
Jon Snow I don't know what he wants he
wants you alive why I don't know I don't
know so what's the point in serving a
god none of us knows what he wants
death is the enemy the first enemy and
the last but we all die the enemy always
wins and we still need to fight him
that's all I know you and I won't find
much joy while we're here but we can
keep others alive we could defend those
who can't defend themselves
I'm the shield that guards the realms of
men maybe we don't need to understand
any more than that maybe that's enough
that's enough after all this show is
literally the Song of Ice and Fire the
melody that Rhaegar composed when he
created his son who would go on to
become the weapon that will kill the
night king and save all Westeros from
the long night now that introduced to be
this interesting fear in you let me also
introduce with some exciting season 8
news I do have to warn you that these
news includes some spoilers for the
upcoming season so if you don't want
anything spoil it's time for you to
close this video anyways season a just
finished filming the longest battle
shooting game of trans history battles
don't take a long time since they're
difficult to film the greatest ones yet
the battle the best resolution ambush
each took about one month of production
time the upcoming Winterfell battle
scene on the other hand requires shoots
at multiple locations that lasted for
about or twice that long it's also
important to say that the end product is
for single episode which means that this
is something that's never been done
before in the history of television
shooting for this largest battle
sequence in Game of Thrones has finally
come to a close after 55 consecutive
nights the producer types shared a thank
you message with all the cast and crew
members who had worked on the sequence
including longtime assistant director
Jonathan 55 consecutive nights three
locations you'll never again see
anything like it this battle Winterfell
will be the biggest most expensive
action scene we've ever seen on TV
another news is the Danish Dragon story
minute Kings Dragon will face new threat
in season 8 in Game of Thrones dragons
have always been a threat Weider's and
not so much the other way around but
season 7 people to be exception to the
rule first run wounded dragon waved
Qyburn scorpion and then the knight king
kill bazarian with an ice spear in
season 8 dragons will face sky burns
latest innovation and anti dragon
warfare Qyburn seemingly decided to
improve his original design by following
the common saying of the bigger the
better
beside being much bigger the new
scorpion also has a new design with two
additional arms presumably to increase
tension these changes could also be due
to the fact that the version we knew was
portable well this funny is one of three
scorpions that will be affixed on kings
Linux walls
whether it's Danny or the knight King
who take their dragons to King's Landing
in season 8 they will face this new and
improved scorpion let's get a little bit
back to Winterfell shooting again as
expected Jaime Lannister will also
participate in his battle against the
army of the Dead Nikolaj coster-waldau
Jaime Lannister and Gwendolyn Christy
Brienne of Tarth were sighted on one
shooting night this means that in
Episode four Jaime and Brienne will be
fighting side by side against the army
of the Dead protecting Winterfell they
were most likely Reno it a bit earlier
but I'm sure these news give us all such
pleasure to know for a fact those two
will finally fight for the same side the
final season a big news that I will
included in sphere is return of Rebecca
Van Cleve for the eighth and final
season of the show you might not
remember this name but this person
certainly did make a huge impression
back in the season 5 finale in which she
was Lina had his body double for the
Xerces naked book of atonement the
so-called walk of shame this means that
when a head is Cersei needs a body
double again which means that Cersei
most certainly have one or more scenes
of an intimate nature in the final
season if I have to guess her civil
heavier childbirth or the wedding night
return both possibilities are likely to
come true and both will require a body
double if the show intends to show more
of Circe's body there you have it guys
just don't lie bring your theory in the
biggest season 8 news so far